avec nous à l'intention de faire un très
bon soir à vous deux
est ce que c'était luc ferrandez une
réponse attendue il fallait qu'elle se
repositionne sur ce sujet qui va être un
conte incontournable dans la campagne la
sécurité des montréalais oui absolument
et là il faut il faut constater qu' il
ya eu un changement de cap parce que
pendant les deux dernières années deux
trois dernières années c'est pas de ça
pour parler on parlait beaucoup des
caméras corporelle on parlait beaucoup
des arrestations avec décès notamment
auprès des personnes souffrant de
problèmes de santé mentale d'une police
plus communautaire et plus sociale plus
psychosocial et là ça évite la question
des gangs de rue est en croissance à
montréal à laval à ottawa à toronto et
je trouve que la réaction de madame
planté de monsieur coderre sont des
réactions électorale c'est de dire on va
mettre plus d'argent mais est ce que le
programme parce qu'une façon de faire
face au problème on n'a pas tendu en bon
initiation
parce que il y avait des gens qui
avaient l'impression après le congrès du
parti madame plantes que on allait vers
au contraire ne m'ont pas ratatiner la
police passait hasan était défendue mais
là elle veut bien montrer qu approche au
sérieux la politiquement c'est
politiquement et électoralistes parce
que si vous lisez bien l'article
ça va être en vigueur l'embauchent des
quarante deux policiers l'année
prochaine donc on annonce aujourd'hui en
grande pompe qui va y avoir 5.5 millions
depuis que le problème va se régler mais
se réglera pas aujourd'hui c'est comme
les pompiers qui vont éteindre un feu
qui ont police d'outils en valeur 10
l'année prochaine on va avoir les outils
on viendra il est trop tard le feu et
poignées dans cabane il faut qu'on
trouve une solution je comprends que
l'on est en campagne électorale c'est
pour ça que ça sort mais c'est
maintenant qu'on doit gérer maintenant
voit que ce soit trop tard pillé déjà un
peu tard et 23h55 dans ce dossier là il
faut le prendre au sérieux lorsqu'on
parle de police et pour défendre la
population puis actuellement nous gagne
de rue ont décidé de prendre la place
les armes ayant des responsabilités qui
sont pas justes à la ville projette à la
police mais aussi à la justice parce
qu'actuellement quelqu'un qui est prêt
avec un arbre une peine ridicule donc
pas assez pour faire peur aux jeunes de
se promener avec des armes à feu il va
falloir que la société aux complices
dans l'écosystème fédérale provinciale
c'est la sphère de tout le monde pas
juste la fin alors je résume vous étiez
des relations publiques ce qu'on a
entendu hier luc oui
mais regardez depuis 1990 la criminalité
a énormément chuté à montréal énormément
plu du plus de la moitié des missions de
la criminalité à presque tous les
domaines l'an passé sera augmentée et ça
augmente et dans le domaine très précis
de la possession des armes à feu est
d'usagé d'armes à feu mais ça a diminué
dans le nombre de crimes alors faut
comprendre que on n'a pas un problème
d'une ville violente on a un problème de
gangs de rue violence ça nous arrive pas
juste à nous ça arrive dans plein de
pays je lisais aujourd'hui en suède un
pays social démocrate un pays où il ya
peu ou pas de violence dans l'art est à
population mais au niveau des gangs de
rue le plus de violences d' en europe
donc c'est un problème lié aux gangs de
rue et à la possession d'armes par ces
gangs la lime le maire la mairesse qui
cliquent ce qu'ils soient vos pour
pouvoir régler ce problème là dans les
faces il ment dans les mois qui vont
suivre par l'embauché de 40 personnes
ont il va falloir qu'ils mettent en
place des problèmes des programmes de
surveillance des programmes de
communautaire des problèmes des
programmes de présence policière il va
falloir qu'ils se positionnent sur c'est
quoi les outils de surveillance qu'on
veut se donner et affectivement faut
qu'ils fassent pression pour avoir des
modifications sur le dpn et qui sont
apportées à ces gens là quand il faut
qu'ils fassent pression sur le fédéral
sur la possession d'armes de poing
l'homme sait pas c'est pas le fait qu'on
met 40 personnes qui vont régler le
problème des mémos tech bon et à laval
et longueuil regarde on veut 10on le
cercle un plus à laval ya eu des points
de presse ou six ippons ça le chef de
police est plus agressif dans les médias
pour dire on fait quelque chose
longueuil qu'est ce que j'avais à dire
être écoutés il ya des solutions
longueur et c'est un des plus beaux
exemples l'orgueil vient de recevoir la
semaine dernière un prix des chefs de
police canadiens sur sa façon d'agir
avec les gens dans longueuil combien
hutues diane dans longueuil
c'est quelqu'un de montréal qui est allé
la mort et pourquoi parce qu'il ya des
programmes de prévention surtout la
prévention passe en politique n'est pas
payant campagne électorale on annonce la
prévention dans le poids de vos peuples
sauf que sur le terrain dans les années
qui suivent on a des résultats et c'est
ce qui s'est passé avec le commandeur un
nouveau directeur de poitiers le fait
d'ailleurs et la prévention la proximité
de ces policiers envoyés ces policiers
dans la rue allez voir les citoyens à
aller voir les jeunes allaient parler
aux gens c'est à s'observer la police de
proximité à montréal rencontrer les gens
créer des climats de confiance pour
pouvoir échanger avec eux et tant qu'on
a eu on remettra pas ces barrières l'eau
sur le période quand même un peu et en
est un peu mais beaucoup moins parce que
c'est plus populaire la prévention mais
si on a manqué le bateau moi j'aimerais
entendre le maire de le maire le maire
de longueuil sexuelle monsieur bois de
la vague se boyer pas ce que fait une
sortie 13 4 jours avec son chef de
police et sur monsieur brochet sur
l'augmentation du nombre de cas où c'est
à laval et à laval 38 d'événements avec
arme à feu depuis le début de l'année
c'est énorme c'est gigantesque et il ya
eu un livre vert qui était déposé une
proposition qui était posée par le spvm
en disant faudra faire une fusion des
polices de montréal longueuil et laval
la proposition a été refusée après ça y
est le comité d'étude qui est
effectivement ils veulent et 10 à
vouloir une première une police de
proximité mais on est ce temps il ya eu
il ya eu une fusillade dans un bar à
longueuil en 2016 où a été retrouvé le
criminel
ak oui il ya pas été retrouvé à
longueuil à laval c'est pareil les armes
de poing qui circulent la circulent dans
toute la région de montréal passe par
les réserves de de cocteau pardon de
quoi ça ce n'est par exemple
mais surtout après assassiner les sont
distribués par d'autres moyens ils
arrivent en pièces par la poste est ce
qu'une police de longueuil ou de laval
peut régler les problèmes comme la
traite des personnes et la possession
d'armes à feu tout seul juste sur son
territoire poser la question c'est y
répondre un peu d'âme ans que non mais
il faudra voir comment les je reviens
montréal et deux candidats principaux
votre plan monsieur coderre vont pas se
démarquer dans leur proposition est ce
que ça va être toujours plus plus plus
de policiers ou pas avoir jamais ça va
être plus que ceci nous permet pas tout
il va falloir qu'il ya un plan d'action
et concret on peut pas juste mettre des
policiers ces règles europol problème il
faut aller la racine qu'il faut vraiment
commencer de la base voir paris d'avant
de la sécurité mais je vous quitte sur
une note positive l'esplanade tranquille
on l'entend attendu beaucoup beaucoup de
temps j'avais fin de vie de quartier moi
je pense l'an dernier là dessus les gens
se demandaient si ben est long avez vous
été mêlé à saint luc ferrandez dans ce
projet de oui je te revient sur ben oui
mais à un niveau c'est pas moi j'avais
les mains dans la pâte de 7 à christine
gosselin qui s'était occupé de ça mais
c'est que grâce au comité des grands
projets j'avais été émerveillés immigrés
musulmans émerveillé par ce que ce
qu'ils vont construire c'est un si on
construit un bâtiment le long qu'il y
ait coupé un mur aveugle depuis peu avec
des restaurants et des sages qui vont
donner sur le pâtis d'art rock savez
tout une musique vazquez pas juste du
patinage ça va ya des gens qui vont
rentrer dans un restaurant qui m'ont
regardé le patinage magnifique amis
cherchent en vain les rangs des insurgés